thank you
[Music]
are you a fan of Elon Musk yeah what are
you looking at what other Elon is there
that you were what are you looking at
focus on the people in the conversation
are you kind of Elon Musk
answer the question James I like you all
the basketball is I like his um
face
oh he's got a good face nice yeah what
do you like about his face it's really
um
face like
and also it's like a statue face like I
could see his face in the Statue you
kind of because he's got the same thing
going on I do yeah yeah you have a
statue face yeah you are statuesque yeah
you look like a Greek god wow oh yeah
dude look at those buys bro come on but
it's only your face I just wanna you
have a fit face like a bust out of you
you know like a bust that's what they do
called that's what they call it yeah
they're called that man about Elon Musk
I could have a bust with a t what's up
with a t yeah
okay I guess it's just me and Anthony
that know what a bust is you know about
a bus
no do you know about it yeah but could
you tell us you know about a bus did you
know for the people who don't know I
didn't know about a bus man it's like
you see like [ __ ] Napoleon you know
it's just the head yeah that's what I'm
saying that's right yeah I got it but
the question is are you about a bust
[Laughter]
okay I do like evos yeah we have
Nickelodeon now
all right so um when do you learn about
the word bust anyways do you know what I
mean when you go to the [ __ ] Museum
man
that's what they're called your first
field trip to museum they always tell
you like oh that's a bus because it's a
statue that doesn't happen
grow up in America and they didn't I
didn't go to the museum it's useless
knowledge really you did grow up in
America yeah you're [ __ ] useless dude
you're useless yeah YouTube [ __ ]
I'm sorry Nick he's getting comfortable
it's okay you have to embarrass me in
front of all my friends you invest me
first dude what did I do could you help
me I'm always trying to help you a few
videos ago he's like oh thank you that's
very nice now he's like yeah you're
useless [ __ ] yeah damn
Jesus Taiwan east side is really showing
I failed the tag because I felt like I'm
the only one that doesn't know what the
bust is everyone else was silence your
life perfectly fine not knowing and
that's kind of what tells you you don't
really need to know that I I know two
minutes this conversation was [ __ ]
you know useless you made it dude that's
useless and Elon are you about to bust I
mean never mind uh you on such a pervert
he um
recently can we focus on the article
guys can we say
don't you have to get on here by six
yeah huh do you want you want to make
your flight yep I have the remote I have
the power
all he needs is one click all right so
um he revealed recently because uh there
was a an employee who was leaking
confidential information about Tesla to
the Press uh back around like 2008 and
he was recently asked on Twitter how he
caught this employee and he revealed on
Twitter how he did it and it's
relatively smart I mean the guy's kind
of a smart guy right how do you do it
she's got structure but he's also smart
use the search function on Gmail
how do you think you would do it
obviously none of us would probably
guess this but how would you catch
somebody working at your company who's
really like leaking confidential
information out will you find who has
the information I know what I would do I
know what I would do too should go first
I would
um tell everybody a very piece of
specific information and see if that
information gets leaked yeah the wrong
infantry like The Departed and then I
would tell it to only so many people and
do that through like a trial and error
period and see
where that came from well what if like
the information they said they don't
leak it but then they leaked the other
one that is well I guess you have to
keep trial there
information you're leaking is real
[ __ ] juicy right enough for some but
it's still incorrect information so you
know where the source came from yeah
that's very good it has to be so
enticing where like this dude is like
licking his [ __ ] lips hearing the
information he's reading the email and
then he's like I can't wait to tell my
peeps but what if they're like you know
what because I did this juicy thing that
is for me but I'm not going to leak that
one but do I mean no no yeah well maybe
because it's the most important for this
thing like they they did this one the
this first one but he's doing fake ones
right so it's like let's say they have a
new they have a new car that's going to
be electric they go hey we got this new
hydrogen-powered car and then so if it
gets back around oh hydrogen power cars
oh it's [ __ ] Nick said it yeah
exactly but what if you said the
hydrogen power car and then I don't say
it but then no you won't you won't find
them but the first one you said is like
a water power car and I leave this in I
didn't know hydrogen is water okay
Anthony I don't know about the [ __ ]
stump what is it stop stop statues thumb
face thumb face half stunt face that's
what they should name it in the first
place anyways
yeah but if okay so if they're okay like
a Mountain Dew powered car all right and
then I leaked that and then that was
[ __ ] up then we know you leaked it no
no but then you don't know yet right
because Elon Musk don't know yet is a
thing no he knows probably he knows so
what he's saying is something leaks
right you go oh [ __ ] I don't know who
leaked it yeah so the the five people I
talked to I'm gonna give them a second
round of information oh
second round information on the same
topic so that way you can engage I see
the difference of information that's
being given yeah that's very good I
thought you didn't grow up in America so
you don't know these tactics right yeah
wait bar what was your idea the same
exact point oh really yeah yeah so
that's good that's that's exactly right
that's exactly this
um
[Laughter]
basically basically this is basically
called a canary trap has ever anybody
ever heard that term no yeah that's
that's apparently a more popularized
version of what you would call uh
putting out the different types of
information to see which one you learned
that your first field trip to the zoo
watch the canaries yeah when you think
about Elon Musk and you think about
Tesla and you think about the entire
company you know he can't just spend
time trialing and erroring one person at
a time and trying to see which
information gets leaked out plus he
doesn't have a million things of fake
information to send out and stuff like
that so what he ended up doing or
whatever his team or we'll just give him
the credit because he's just [ __ ]
apparently brilliant is he put a binary
code secretly in emails that he sent out
to everyone and this binary code was
um comprised of the amount of single or
uh double spaces after periods in
between sentences oh my God that's
really Advanced so it was like hard to
to see which one in an entire email
everybody get the same email in terms of
text all the same information but each
email maybe you had one space after a
period maybe the next one had two spaces
and it'll just be a binary code like
that but nobody can see that with their
their naked eye test reading so fast
you're reading a work email holy [ __ ]
and then once that one was sent out it
was automatic I'm guessing he has some
[ __ ] algorithm or software as well or
maybe he just had a bunch of [ __ ]
nerds sitting there just counting every
single one but point is once that was
forwarded it triggered the [ __ ] thing
and that's crazy well I was gonna say
that if you didn't like cut me off and
uh fun and Bulldogs yeah bulldoze me
dude that's good say that like I'm sorry
I should have given you the floor and
the opportunity of written code to find
out who was snitching on me and [ __ ]
that's what I would have done binary
code binary code
and that's what I was gonna say when he
was asked obviously after he had found
we had our own Elon Musk dude I'm good
at Tech stuff it's pretty cool I could I
could like
I can hook up a printer pretty good
that's it let's say let's say you bring
home the juice
yeah right and then you and then uh you
had a family member one of your sister's
staying with you someone ate half of it
how would you sniff them out with your
binary code you know I just I hit him up
on BBM Blackberry Messenger yeah yeah
send out a little more actually no I
would know that my wife would never eat
my cold watermelon because she knows I
would put something in the food but
let's say like let's not like wow geez
like egg slacks
sure but like let's say it's like a
sandwich I'd put something super spicy
so if like somebody reacts to that I'd
be like oh I know you ate my food yeah
but you like spicy but then you gotta
eat that [ __ ] too yeah but let's say
like you don't eat your own traps
exactly oh you're trying to trap so like
let's say something let's say something
and uh somebody here in JK news keeps
eating my lunch okay okay
and so today I'm gonna plan to not eat
my lunch and I'm gonna put something
really spicy in it yeah
exactly
right yeah
what if I don't react to your spicy do
you mean I'm just sweating
and that's not reacting yeah that's a
reaction I don't know but I go I'm hot
you know and then maybe Bart eats it but
he doesn't sweat when he's spicy well
you would put something that would be
substantial enough
some sort yeah but I'm not in the
bathroom
are you sitting there are you kidding
you know what you could do to counter
that is just break the AC so we're all
sweating
yeah but he would have to know ahead and
you don't know why like he eats a
sandwich he's like oh [ __ ] she's on to
me
somebody handled the sweatiest the
sweatiest video we've ever had not even
turn on the heater just break the AC but
on top of that on top of that all of us
also stole our lunch
who has all shared it amongst yourself
yeah damn was that sounded spicy for you
too
that corner of the sandwich it was super
spicy I'm just like oh geez
did somebody break the AC
foreign